back in Davos Switzerland President
Trump also spoke about his former
national security adviser John Bolton
and whether he should give testimony in
the impeachment trial let's listen
I would rather interview Bolton
I would rather interview a lot of people
the problem with John is that it's a
national security problem you know you
can't have somebody who's at national
security and if you think about it John
he knows some of my thoughts he knows
what I think about leaders what happens
if he reveals what I think about a
certain leader and it's not very
positive and then I have to deal on
behalf of the country it's gonna be very
hard it's gonna make the job very hard
he knows other things and I don't know
if we left on the best of the terms I
would say probably not you know and so
you don't like people testifying when
they didn't leave on good terms and that
was due to me not due to him chief
Washington correspondent major Garrett
joins us now major good morning what's
your reaction to what the president just
said there well the White House has made
it very clear to me lots of senior
administration officials have that if
John Bolton is somehow and this is a
very remote possibility currently
subpoenaed by the Senate for this trial
the White House would immediately
asserted executive privilege and say
much of the conversations between the
former national security adviser and the
present United States are classified
therefore this would lead to a
protracted court fight delaying the
Senate proceeding for weeks if not
months and the White House would fight
at every step of the way so the
president sounds sort of equivocal on
this but the White House legal strategy
is anything but was it surprising to you
major to hear him say listen he didn't
leave on good terms and I said some
things about people that I wouldn't want
repeated and it could be very awkward
was it surprising to hear him say that
no it sounds to me the president is
anticipating the book that John Bolton
is writing and if that's all the space
taken up by John Bolton's public
testimony meeting a book the president
can live with that John Bolton is
writing a book the president knows he is
someone who likes to sort of be a truth
teller on the outside having once been
on the inside that sounds to me the
president is anticipating that sort of
problem in the future
but everything the White House is trying
to accomplish with Senate Republicans is
to keep John Bolton out of the
impeachment mix but major is the White
House and President Trump gonna have
control over the question of witnesses
we saw Mitch McConnell who thought he
had a consensus on the rules have to
make two concessions could that signal
more twists and turns ahead it could but
I would remind those watching that those
concessions were very small and very
much at the margins and the super
structure that Mitch McConnell has built
for his Senate Republicans which is to
have a series of votes much much later
in the process on the question of
witnesses and documents still remains
and it is that superstructure that the
White House favors and that still places
a very very high bar against new
witnesses and documents which would
speed this trial up and give the White
House precisely what it wants major as
we've been saying for a couple of days
the Democrats need for Republicans if
they're gonna get Witnesses on the stand
what's your sense behind the scenes
there whether they have those could have
those votes well look all the votes
yesterday are very telling remember what
happened on the house side every time
there was a vote House Republicans were
completely locked in arms on the
president's side there were 12 votes
yesterday 11 on democratic amendments
and one on the Republican organizing
proposal Republicans were lockstep there
that's a signal of the future all right
major Garrett forests in Washington
major thank you very much
you